crews from fema are on the ground
they're going door to door
in las vegas to help combat the rise in
covid cases by sharing vaccine
information
the secretary of the department of
health and human services
xavier becerra and governor sisolak
sharing more on those efforts today
joe moeller with those details more than
99 percent of those who are dying today
from covid
are unvaccinated secretary of the
department of health and human services
xavier becerra and governor steve
siselek joined forces to address the
recent rise in copen 19 cases in
southern nevada
those variants are going to keep coming
if we don't get ahead of this
thursday becerra shared how the federal
government is here to help
fema has sent surge response teams they
are canvassing certain hard-hit zip
codes throughout las vegas to pass out
vaccination information
thank you for doing this for going out
there
and touching people where they need
where you need to find them because
sometimes they can't come to us
he says these teams are here at syslax
request and they're focusing on the
areas
in particular that have extremely low
vaccination rates and that's where
they're going and
we're putting up pop-ups and then
sending the cert teams in to help with
that
search teams are being sent to a number
of cities experiencing spikes syslak and
bisera visited a pop-up clinic at the
sherman gardens community center
both say getting more people vaccinated
at clinics like this will help combat
the rising cases and hospitalizations we
are experiencing
well i'm worried that we don't get a
handle on it but my hopes are that we do
get a handle on it right now we're like
they say having the surge teams here
fema on the ground is definitely making
a big big difference
joe moeller 8 news now the efforts to
get more and more people vaccinated
are ongoing the secretary even
mentioning opening more clinics at
popular places
even in and out burger he says the
federal government will be here to help
as
long as they can